[موسيقى]
محمد عبد الحميد عندي
مهمه جدا جدا في الحياه وهي على الصداقه
حاجه
اي رقم الصداقه بالنهايه وصديق وقت الديك
وعلى فكره الصداقه دي حاجه مهمه جدا في
الحياه مثلا انتم كلكم كبرتوا كده
اي صديق هيجي لكم اكتئاب طول الحياه بدل
اصحاب طول الحياه
وانت لازم تساعد صاحبك وهو يساعدك وانت
لقيت مثلا صاحبك غلط وانت عارف غلط وممكن
يقصف شخصيته لازم تقول له لا مصاحبهوش زي
ما حصل معي معي
صاحبت واحده صغيره ومش عارفه هي بتعاملني
وحش
وكانت بتخليني اضايق الناس بموهبتي هي
الرسم بتخليني اضيقهم بها وانا مش عارفه
لغايه ما قبلت وعائلتي في اولى ابتدائي
وبقيت اعرف كانت بتعاملني وحش دايما
مش بتخليني اصاحب اي احد غيرها
هي عملتني وحش جدا انا قلت لها انا خلاص
هبعد عنك وهي كمان عملت كده من يومها هي
عماله تعمل كده
لكن من يومها انا عماله اصاحب واصاحب
وصاحب لغايه ما هي جت بنفسها واعتذرت لي
وانا سامحتها وصاحبه اصحابي وبقينا كلنا
اصحاب كل ده عشان انا سامحتها
[تصفيق]